the Joe Rogan experience that you bring
in the fact that we're living in such a
grim moment what I'd call you know an
American Empire in decline and we all
need to call for his regeneration as
Democratic revitalization and
regeneration but how do we do that
only by example man because there's a
difference between what the great
Roberto Unger calls own biographical
time and historical time all of us are
born in circumstance is not of our own
choosing we're only here for so long we
all have insecurities anxieties and
fears knowing that our body's willing to
go extinction when they very soon and
therefore to deal with those
insecurities and fears and anxieties you
have to have certain structures of
feeling and valued it gives you some
sense of worth wildness as you move to
time from mother's womb to tomb right
and it's only in biographical time
because we only got one life decided
Jordan and there's no person who's a
messiah nowadays people will tell you
they are but you say okay just go at it
be self deceived and drink your cognac
and keep moving because there's no
messiahs out there there's no saviors
out there there's no messiahs and groups
there's no messiahs and collectivities
there's only lives to be live we back to
check off again
lives to be lived acknowledging things
were in place before we arrives so
therefore we ought to have gratitude for
the love that we received that's how I
begin my my whole life I am Who I am
because somebody loved me his mom it's
dad it's my brother's my sisters it's my
friends right and I don't deserve it and
I had to somehow following ashford wins
a student Simpson they say send it like
a puff of smoke you got to let it go
spread whatever love justice by example
examples are the gold cart of justice
that's a wonderful line inconsequently
core pure reason examples are the gold
cart of judgment the judgments we make
are predicated on the examples that we
have
and we must have examples of greatness
if you're gonna be a classical composer
you better study some loot betta you're
gonna be a serious artist of the musical
theater you better study a genius who's
still alive named Stephen Sondheim hmm
from West Side Story the company to
Sunday in the park with George - passion
- Sweeney Todd across the board not to
imitate but just to know what greatness
is in your genre if you in hip-hop you
better study some Rakim hmm whoo-whoo
you better study some follow-the-leader
have to put Tupac that's right you best
studied the folk look great it's the
same way you know you study Pryor and
Bruce Lenny Bruce and the others and
Roseanne Barr and the others
[Applause]